I want to say
it has been our tradition
to toast with you
at the top of every hour.
We will be doing that
Here's how this is going to work.
You don't know this.
Okay, so here's not alcohol, not alcohol.
See, I like this
because there's a lot of people
who are not drinking at home.
Yes, a lot of people are,
but a lot of people are.
So they can.
But they can do
all can take a toast with us
at the top of every hour.
What do we do?
Cause what we are doing is
we are taking a mystery shop out.
Here's how this is going to work.
Anderson
and I will put on our Ramona eyes.
What are Ramona?
Ramona eyes are Ramona eyes.
And they block us out. We can't see.
What do they look like?
We are go. Don't worry about it.
We're going to do a shot.
That's the point.
Okay. Okay.
Here, Anderson, put your hand out
and take this shot.
We are going to do
a mystery shot on the screen.
It will say what we are doing.
We will take the shot,
and then we will guess what it was.
Sounds fun.
I think so. It could be a smell.
I don't know. I'm not going to smell it.
I am not going to smell it
because I'm freaked out, you know,
because honestly, for me,
this is no different
because alcohol to me, I know.
Disgusting.
Okay, so you all at home know what it is?
We don't.
Okay, at the count of three,
we're going to do it. Okay. Okay.
And then cheers. You guys happy new year.
It's our first shot of the night.
You guys at home? Play along.
One, two, three.
Oh, I need it now.
What's up with that tomato juice?
I hate tomato juice.
So what? That was.
Wait, what was it?
Was it tomato juice?
It's on the screen.
Pickle juice.
I've never had a pickle.
You've never had it before?
Sweetie,
it's time for a straight shot
for a mystery shot.
Anderson, let's put these Ramona
eyes on you.
Why are this called Ramona?
Because, sweetie,
you don't need to worry about.
Okay, guys, I think mystery shots.
Okay. Here, Anderson.
Okay. Count of three.
You guys at home. Here's how this works.
We want you to have a cocktail with us.
We are not having one,
but we're going to have this
ad on the screen.
You will see what we're about to drink.
And let's do it in three Anderson.
One, two, three.
Ow!
Oh!
Oh! Ow!
Oh, that was so gross.
I don't know what it's like.
What was that?
What was that? Take it off.
Oh, give me the juice box.
Buttermilk. Buttermilk.
I just milk.
I've always wondered.
One buttermilk
buttermilk I've never known.
I always like. What is butter?
What is buttermilk?
It's just gotta stay put.
Your Ramona ice on.
Okay.
Boy, that buttermilk was so last.
The first hour, we had pickle juice,
which is really revolting.
Okay.
I can't see anything on
just your hand around.
Oh, I'm pretty.
I don't know.
Well, okay.
They're okay.
Okay. Okay.
Counted three.
We don't know. You guys know what it is?
This is I might you at this one.
I could taste the pickle juice still.
Okay, here we go.
Okay. One, two, three.
Two.
Oh.
Oh, that teeth.
What could that be?
Any idea what socks?
Oh, shoes.
Oh, damn. Are we drinking?
Drinking the squeezed juice
of a leather shoe.
That's what I need to get on a
okay.
Well, that's fine. Okay. Sorry.
I think it's good.
Apple cider vinegar.
Oh, wonderful. Here we go.
Counter three cheers, everybody.
Happy New Year.
Thanks for celebrating with us.
We love our communal space together.
Don't.
I don't smell it.
Okay, here we go.
One, two, three.
I right.
Oh, jeez.
It's so good.
It's some kind of gravy.
A gravy off my tongue,
throat, spice, bloody Mary mix.
A spicy Bloody Mary mix.
What is a bloody Mary?
I've never understood.
It's like tomato juice.
What's it become then?
Why not? Then there's no vodka in there.
This is killed.
That shot.
Oh, my God.
I have a little juicy juice left.
Wow. Okay, I'm okay.
Joining us
now is one of the funniest actors
and comedians in the game,
and he is performing
tonight at Resorts World, Las Vegas.
Kevin Hart is here Kevin and Kevin,
how are you?
Do and happy New Year.
Happy New Year, guys.
What was what was.
What's going on?
I can't believe this right now.
I'm watching you guys
and you are completely sober.
This is disappointing.
I know you're sober. I know.
I know it. Yeah.
What is it? We're.
Yeah, yeah.
You know what?
Yeah, you
you can't say anything about it.
I can.
I can say things about this is absolute.
I don't like it. One
I'ma say what you want to say.